Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday.
I have a flu-like illness, so you should prepare
yourself for the worst vlogbrothers video
ever.
To make it slightly more entertaining, I'm
gonna play some Project for Awesome livestream
highlights, so you don't have to look at my
sick mug.
So, Hank, this whole thing started while Henry
was giving me Sharpie face on Saturday morning
during the Project for Awesome, and I felt
a little tickle in my throat.
I thought it was Sharpie fumes, and, you know,
maybe it was, maybe Sharpies caused my illness.
But, at any rate, yeah, now I'm miserably
ill, which sucks, because there are only a
few days left in the Paper Towns shoot, and
I wanna be with those people because awesome
things are happening today in a minivan.
But I also don't wanna get them sick because
they still have to finish the movie.
More importantly, the Project for Awesome
has raised over $1.2 million for charity,
by far the most successful P4A of all time.
Nerdfighters, thanks to all of you who donated,
who made P4A videos, who watched them, and
shared them, and commented, and watched the
live show.
I don't know what you guys thought of this
year's Project for Awesome -- I'm interested
to hear in comments, but for me it was definitely
the best one yet, at least until I was stuck
by this terrible Sharpie illness.
John-from-livestream: Cover it with Sharpie,
yes!
Henry-from-livestream: No, I don't wanna cover
it.
John-from-livestream: Oh, you don't wanna
cover it.
Henry-from-livestream: If you cover it guess
what.
John-from-livestream: What?
Henry-from-livestream: You like... get forehead
disease.
Oh, Henry you were so right to be worried
about forehead diseases, which reminds me
to thank my family for their patience and
participation in this year's Project for Awesome,
not least Sarah, who allowed herself to be
covered in jelly.
And I should also mention that the Indiegogo
is still live.
You can donate for the rest of today and today
only, to get amazing perks, from a calendar
featuring YouTubers before they were YouTubers,
to the Project for Awesome exclusive edition
of The Fault in Our Stars.
There's also original art by Minute Physics,
An Imperial Affliction, P4A socks, pressed
pennies, and so much more.
Donations are tax-deductible in the US, and
all of your money after manufacturing costs
and shipping goes to charities that are chosen
by the Nerdfighter community at projectforawesome.com.
Ah, man, this reminds me of when #bananaeyes
trended on Twitter.
Happier days, Hank, happier days.
Sarah-from-livestream: Yay!
John-from-livestream: You look adorable.
How do I look?
Sarah-from-livestream: It's gross.
So Hank, the Foundation to Decrease Worldsuck
works because there's no overhead.
Everyone who packs and ships perks at the
DFTBA Records Warehouse volunteers their time,
as does Sam Rudge, who does the website work,
Karen Kavett, who designs it, Lauren Chernikoff,
and dozens of other people.
So to everyone who was part of this year's
Project for Awesome, thank you, thank you.
We did it!
$1 million!
Actually like 200,000 more than a million.
Hank, here's a sentence I thought I would
never say: you are the most beautiful mummy
dancer the world has ever known.
I'll see you on Friday.